you're the best tv show that i've
watched it came out recently
yeah dude i watched that too dude yeah
oh my god because i was gonna i was
gonna talk about some good [ __ ] that
i've watched
severance is probably one of the most
interesting and best tv shows i've
watched in a long time so sell it to me
all right so uh i'm gonna do a bad
version then gone could do the good
version okay okay
the the the plot of this world is that
uh there is a procedure that you can get
that'll split your mind into two so you
have two consciousness one that goes to
work and one that does everything not
work right right so essentially there'll
be two characters in the same body one
that and they don't have any memories of
the other oh okay okay so the person in
work only existence is work i don't know
anything else right and the person
outside of work only has outside of work
and doesn't know anything else and so
it's kind of really interesting because
it's dealing with all right well if you
only worked all the time you would
probably get miserable and want to not
work all the time so then they're trying
to there's kind of like really
interesting side plots of when they're
trying to
figure out what their outside person is
doing and then the outside person trying
to figure out what the inside person's
doing and the company they work at is
really mysterious we don't really know
what they do and so it's kind of like
and it's very very creepy and
it's really interesting you should watch
it so what's the good version uh that
was actually pretty good uh oh he did it
i'll do it i'll sell extra fluff it up
i'll do the i'll do the bad version i
guess uh imagine black mirror was good
again
that's that's but but they had a good
premise and they ran with it yeah yeah
yeah okay yeah it could cause like i
watched the season it and it felt very
black mirror-esque but like when black
mirror had very interesting ideas and
yeah it wasn't like [ __ ] just miley
cyrus going to like the bottom of the
barrel being like yeah we can make a
[ __ ] episode about this but like it
it has like a very interesting concept
as kind of said and they like run with
it and they explore
every single facet that you know i
wanted to explore out of it lately
definitely bring out like the ethical
aspect about it as well just like
is you know if you separate your
memories is that person essentially a
new person or is it just still you you
know because
you know in a certain
in a certain argument they are both the
same person because you come from the
same personality you know you just you
just don't share the memories of working
and the life outside of work but if you
separate the memories does that mean
that's like two separate people that are
living in one body as well chris chris
really liked it too of course funny
you've watched it it's on apple tv
though which is chris washer it must be
a masterpiece okay liked it too
that sounds really cool though literally
everyone i know who watched it really
enjoyed it it definitely sounds like a
show i would like yeah you know no one's
talking about it it's on apple tv yeah
yeah
like like the only reason that i was
able to watch it was because we were
luckily provided ipads by geeksplus to
use for work and i'm just like great i
have a device to watch it on now perfect
because i couldn't do that before oh
cool i pretty much just saw an article
where they were like apple tv has some
really interesting shows and it came up
and i thought wow that looks really good
yeah and then the reviews were insane
yeah and i thought wow okay and yeah
honestly i really hope it doesn't uh it
doesn't like mess up the landing because
season one
was really really good season one's
really really good and holy [ __ ]
and on a cliffhanger god [ __ ] damn it
oh the but like that's also scary right
because people are saying the same thing
about black mirror as well
they were like damn season one though i
hope they stick the landing
yeah i think black mirror is basically
not going to continue because it's in
like legal
battles for like ownership right yeah
it's in like legal trouble oh [ __ ] i
think when they sold the rights
something was iffy and there's arguments
over who owns the rights to black mirror
so i think pretty much black mirror is
dead damn yeah i think well that doesn't
sadden me too much because they were
definitely like
running out of ideas they're definitely
running out of ideas so something
scratched that itch though and it was
the show yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah did that yeah because
yeah with black mirror i remember like
season one and season two being [ __ ]
incredible yeah and then season three
was just like okay there are some really
good episodes and then some are just
like really weird episodes and then
season four onwards was just like you
are you know why are you playing miley
cyrus on this
i didn't even get to that point yeah
yeah yeah i was even even worse i didn't
even watch season five sucked
yeah so i mean there's only like so many
ideas you can come up with with it being
like an anthology of different ideas but
severance [ __ ] great because it's
just one idea just explored to the
fullest uh very happy
such good acting yeah that is so good
like all these characters are so creepy
yeah like believable
yeah it was perfectly casted as well oh
yeah yeah yeah definitely check it out
yeah before it gets too high yeah yeah
yeah yeah
if if another person starts talking
about it i'll be like no no no no no one
is talking i literally don't know anyone
who's talking i've never seen anyone
talk about it so i yeah
if you want a really interesting thing
i'm gonna watch it then before this
episode goes live in a couple of days
if you watch one episode you'll be
hooked it's one of those yeah
and it's really interesting sure sure uh
yeah watch it if you uh if you can uh
it's really interesting uh actually like
yeah amazing that's awesome speaking
about something that everyone seems to
be talking about now that i have
surprised
i didn't know how big it had gotten here
in the uk even like people who barely
watch anime they're like yo you're
watching spy family oh yeah spike's
family i'm like oh my god everybody i
pronounce the eggs because i'm a chat
yeah i mean it's been a while since i've
just seen an anime just blow up this
quickly i guess because i mean like
right from the get-go was like [ __ ]
solid i mean the manga was insanely
popular in japan yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah i think it was good i was but like
i was i remember i was so scared because
i've been like a fan of the manga for
ages now and when i was like when i was
you know about to watch the first
episode i was like please please let it
be good please don't [ __ ] this up yeah
thank god they didn't right but like i
wasn't expecting yeah as you were saying
like i was not expecting it to be like
the talk of the town essentially yeah
because i expect because i just feel
like holy [ __ ] shone and jump are just
on a different level right now in terms
of in terms of like making mega hitters
because it feels like it feels like when
shown and jump release a new anime it's
like shonen jump and then every other
anime true pretty much because it like
it it doesn't even feel like you're
talking to a anime fan if they say they
watch shonen jump stuff because
everyone's watching shonen jump stuff
imagine if we got a good berserk
adaptation
just imagine well like even even i i
even don't think it would be as popular
as like spy spikes family or demon
slayer or something like that you know i
think the only the only other the only
ip that can really stand up to shonen
jump ips is like attack on titan that's
like that's like the outlier you know
because just a different shonen yeah
yeah final season part one deluxe
edition yeah yeah yeah
yeah but i mean like it's just i haven't
read the manga of spike's family it's
just a really really good show yeah i
like it i haven't watched it i've been
saving it because i want to binge it all
for like one big serotonin boost yeah
yeah it's really solid like even from a
manga read it's really really solid it's
just it's just like it's
there's nothing i can really say about
it other than it's just a good show from
like a good manga with a [ __ ] amazing
adaptation um like they nailed anya like
like as a character they're gonna be
seeing reaction images of her for the
next like four months i know right i
know every every twitter oh my gosh
she's so [ __ ] adorable like she will
single-handedly save japan's like
[ __ ] aging population man depression
been mad quiet since
the japanese population aren't having
enough babies one anya you can have this
you can have this
yeah like because like that was the only
thing i was worried about was like you
know because the dialogue is what made
spy family so [ __ ] good in the manga
so i was like
if they nail the voice acting and the
casting this is going to be huge and
they [ __ ] nailed the casting yeah at
least especially the japanese one like
the voice for anya is like perfect yeah
like what i think the big thing that
really makes it stand out is the cast
really nailed the chemistry between the
mom dad and the daughter yeah yeah
obviously anya gets all the or the
spotlight but just the dynamic um seeing
the dynamic play out between you know if
if you don't know the premise of spike's
family it's a family that has a spy in
it an assassin in it and anya who
is who can read mines that has a
telepathy right it's it's a it's a
really really weird mix of people but
they nail this family dynamic perfectly
because i remember just like it's equal
parts
funny
and wholesome as well yeah i remember
seeing like it's like an ios k that's
actually fun
everything from
a little
sprinkle yeah a little bit a little bit
of everything because i remember like i
remember coming back from uh coming back
from the wedding uh like last weekend
and i remember a little the newest
episode of spike's family just came out
and i watched it and i just thought i
was already like high up in positive
vibes and spike's family like gave me
such wholesome vibes i almost [ __ ]
cried
like just because of how like [ __ ]
happy i felt man
i love how you're just like [ __ ] the
wedding the news my family episode just
came out
that's where my happiness is right now
yeah
yeah i'm just like hold on sydney hold
on before you say your vows all right
i'm ready i'm ready
that's what i'm fighting for right now
are you watching the anime of spike's
family or are you just like no no no i
am actually watching it because like
yeah cause like i watched the first
episode i was like oh [ __ ] this is like
actually a [ __ ] amazing adaptation so
yeah i am watching i'm not caught up to
the latest latest episode but um yeah
i'm like watching it kind of on and off
and uh yeah it's [ __ ] great i can see
why people are hyped about it yeah yeah
but like you know you were saying that
like oh yeah anja's like the new
favorite but like i don't know man i've
seen a lot of [ __ ] yore i have
pictures and it's like oh my god i i
know she carried talking about i don't
even know what their name is you said
the name but yeah i'm guessing it's the
woman yeah yeah yeah i'm like i'm like
oh my god first time in god knows how
many years where wife of the season is
not a high schooler
well done it's it's a mother it's a it's
a lava it's a milk it's actually a milf
thank you well done guys i guess i'll
have to check it
yeah i mean it was it's so weird just
because obviously i expected to be
popular i didn't expect it to be this
popular this quickly even demon slayer
took like 18 episodes yeah to really
burst into support i finally just
literally took like two to see if it uh
sticks around for the entire run
i think it will i would be very
surprised yeah it's only one season
because like the manga is doing like
insane numbers right now as well yeah i
saw like the the manga sales of like the
last the last month in japan and it's
like number one number two number three
number four number five all volumes the
spikes family yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah it comes out
all right
gets a giant boost in sales yeah yeah if
you want to read the manga yeah so i'm
like man sharon and jump just can't miss
right now because this i didn't even
think spike's family was going to it was
going to be the big show that they were
released this year i thought it was
going to be changing man yeah and then
what was that coming out that's coming
out this year as well yeah i think it's
the summer i think
summer
seems like that's been like everyone's
like i'm so hyped for that and i was
like yeah when we hide like a year ago
so fujimoto's released like three one
shots in that space oh my god dude which
you [ __ ] need to read okay yeah he he
brought out like i recently ran like a a
one shot uh called goodbye airy right by
him and it's like it's [ __ ] amazing
it's like probably one of the best one
shots i've ever read like the dude
manages to like
like basically
give the plot of like a movie's worth of
plot in like 200 pages oh wow and it's
[ __ ] incredible like yeah i read it
the other day because like twitch chat
was like have you already read it and so
i was like and you can read it for free
as well
on the uh on the john plus uh i'm making
it sound like an ad i'm not even paid
for this [ __ ] yeah thank you thanks joey
i'll wait for my writing they need us to
shout them out to know that
exists
is on another [ __ ] level
yeah i've uh
shout out to disney by the way
the stuff you're doing with marvel or
whatever waiting for the royalties to
disney
walt i'm getting i'm waiting for your
call walt
yeah i mean i'm sorry because like even
this like disney now have also come into
like the anime race you know [ __ ]
um they they've picked up one of the
best seasonal animes i think our area is
air in the season which is like
summertime render which uh no one can
really watch right now because it's on
disney plus it's on disney plaza what's
the [ __ ] yeah yeah it's on disney and
it's a disney
[Laughter]
one more anime that was aired like a
couple of seasons back is in these eight
plus as well
your
for
is that actually yeah
i see ads on on like facebook like
everyone's like wish i could see on
disney plus
that's so weird
what a weird timeline we're living in
where disney is like you have your kids
ever heard of
anime that's so weird it's so surreal to
think that it's gotten to this point
where now disney's getting involved in
the anime arms race i thought they just
like they they had that thing with
ghibli you know i never thought they
cared about like anything else yeah like
i always thought like disney's like idea
of anime was just like princess mononoke
yeah that's a movie yeah is it anyway is
it made by hayao miyazaki oh no okay um
i guess it just it doesn't exist it
doesn't exist yeah
oh my god